guys before the video starts please help
me to reach my target for the winter
appeal for palestine and gaza people are
literally freezing we will never live in
those conditions help me reach my target
to give them some warmth
as your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to zinna well we're here to
tell you you're not alone itasca is the
place where muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh
brothers and sisters and dear friends
i'm going to keep this video long now mr
beast is maybe one of the biggest
youtubers um on youtube and he does some
very interesting videos and he helps a
lot of people does competitions and all
this kind of stuff sometimes if i come
across it's not something i watch but i
do know one thing that a lot of kids
watch it a lot of kids muslims and
non-muslims now before you watch it i
want you guys to be a bit cautious why
because i was sent this ad
a friend showed me that he was on the
video etc and this ad played now this ad
is very very disturbing and we would
like this video to be sent to mr beast
to block such ads because kids watch
this and what i saw shocked me
absolutely sickening i'm not saying it's
his fault nobody's having to go at him
like i said before this video is not for
that this video is just to raise
awareness that these certain ads should
be blocked as muslims because of
religious reasons would block alcohol
pornography or all this well soft
pornography or what you define as
pornography these days you know anyways
so
what i found is very disturbing now what
you see on the screen is the ad that was
sent to me yeah
and i've blurred it out because i don't
want you guys to go and look at it
but
when you go onto their page and you can
see on the screenshots guys yeah this is
absolutely disturbing so when i went on
the page because i wanted to see what is
this about as you can see on there on
the ads it says something like oh and by
the way kids if you're watching this
please view this question's advice
please switch off and do not watch this
yeah okay
but you can clearly see there there
there's a woman there in a very
you know uh promiscuous way you know a
seductive way saying oh i didn't know it
was that big
now we wonder what uh she's probably
talking about here yes okay all right i
i very highly doubt uh they're talking
about the eiffel tower here yeah so
anyways when you go onto the website on
this site and i'm gonna block some
people don't find it this
thing on the top which you see the word
m was on
now to me
that was shocking
because i went on there and i was like
thinking okay it's maybe some kind of a
cartoonish
thing whatever it may be but i was
absolutely gobsmacked because it was
literally pornography it was pornography
i couldn't believe my eyes and when you
go to the website which my friend sent
me so as soon as i clicked it you go
went to the page etc it was okay none of
that like there was nothing going on and
then i went to daily i [ __ ] what was
this about this seemed okay there was
nothing it was just like a story episode
one yes even then this is like some
woman was dressed up inappropriately
except like very inappropriate and by
the way these are cartoon uh yeah okay
they're not real um uh individuals yeah
but they're already dressed up in a
weird way and then i went to daily
now when you go to daily guys
it is pornography though
now very interesting the top left button
the m i think that stands for mature now
when you press mature like it was
pornography
when i saw it i was like my gosh
this is pornography it is pornography in
a cartoon version when you turn which is
more shocking is the following when you
turn that m button off yeah and all it
did was first ask me is are you over 18
when i press the mature section yeah and
when i pressed i said okay let me see
like yes and i was thinking yes 18 plus
it might show something it's in a
cartoon way um but
it was literally pornography literally
pornography when you press the m button
which is turns it off yeah you go to a
section where it shows you kid stuff
like it's just your general
kid stuff that you're watching yeah okay
but the fingers which you see on the
screen is the moment you turn the m off
and turn the m back on it goes back to
pornography
it's as good as a child going there
easily all it said is over 18 all have
to do is press the yes button anybody
can press the yes button any there was
no measures in place to identify or
prove that this person is 18 is as good
as my child watching cartoon and while
he's watching this cartoon there's a
button on top that presses and when you
press it all the anim the characters in
the cartoon turn into um
pornography actors and they
have an intimacy literally literally
so this is just a short video and please
send this to mr beast
it might what you are not watching it's
irrelevant to me okay
to block these ads because there are
kids watching these there are muslims it
doesn't matter you're muslim
there are innocent kids watching this
and we know what kind of a filthy
disgusting society we're already living
in and we do not want to expose them
further and be sexualized and sexualize
them in this hypersexualized society
already and corrupt them further let
kids be kids and live as kids for god's
sake so please send this video to him we
hope mr beast would block these but it's
very disturbing uh to see and it's
unbelievable so please uh parents
protect your children and be careful to
what they watch because that ad is just
a click away and they can be they can go
to that website and then that website
the m button is already turned on yeah
on or even if it's off automatically
your kids are going to be exposed to
something very very dangerous that could
lead them to actual official real-life
pornography lastly allah says shaytan is
an enemy and take him as an enemy parent
be careful because the shaytan has waged
a war on mankind from day one and he
wants to take everybody down to hellfire
with him and anybody that's suffering
from pornography do not forget to check
my task which they are coaches experts
who are on this field who are helping
people to stop watching pornography and
get their lives back together from this
field